there's some good ones up there i'm
trying to think of
when it comes if i was gonna prank
anybody on our on stranger things
i'd probably pick
[Music]
what's going on i have no clue you're on
my show prank encounters
peyton you know that i love you and that
you and i go
way back wait i've been interviewing you
since you were like
11 or something like that yeah like like
13
probably but i need to be honest with
you if i
was one of your people that you pranked
on prank encounters
i might hit you okay you see that's
definitely something i'm usually scared
of going into them is that i'm gonna
find someone
who very much wants to hit me
that's so scary usually once you reveal
that this has
all been a prank they're just so
relieved and excited and like flooded
with endorphins has there ever been
someone who reacted
almost angry most of the anger happens
before the reveal
which i'm thankful for because i'm in
i'm in our control room at that point
nobody's ever reacted to uh the reveal
with anger i think most people are so
caught up in the fact that they are
they now know that they're safe from
danger that they can't help but just
feel relieved which i'm happy about i've
never been so
relieved to see you in my life one of my
favorite moments that we had
i run into a room before i even mention
that i'm on a show
one of our march looked at me and goes
ugh
really of course like i feel like
i know who you are everyone should know
who you are but one contestant looked at
you and said
am i supposed to know who you are yeah
uh-huh
a couple of them have no idea they never
a lot of them have never heard of prank
encounters more people know me from my
work constraint through things
but a lot of them have never seen
stranger things and a lot of them have
never seen my work before or familiar
with me and so i go in for the reveal in
what should be a moment of
oh whoa look there's that kid from that
show they're still like
who's this guy okay things are about to
get nuts
oh my god has there ever been a prank
that's gone
wrong oh yeah really and what happens
any kind of prank goes wrong
it never is this like big dramatic
fiasco it usually is very anticlimactic
it's very like it crumbles at the seams
and like
something happens there's a reveal that
happens too early or a mark
catches on to something they weren't
intended to catch on to i don't think
anyone's ever seen a camera but
sometimes they'll catch on
and like a crew member will be spotted
somewhere or something like that and
it's very funny to me
because while they're all weirded out
everybody around them is like ugh
we'll get them next time and all of a
sudden a set opens up and they're like
what is happening right now because then
they look around and they're like what
who who are they and they're like oh
yeah you're on a prank show
sorry it didn't go as planned the most
we've ever had to redo a prank in one
day was three times
though it takes quite a bit of time to
film a prank ideally
what's condensed down into about a half
hour episode
ends up being over two and a half three
hours of footage so it really is
quite such a pain if it doesn't work out
exactly
it can be quite frustrating because it
takes a bit
to get somebody comfortable in a
situation you always get nervous but the
only person that ever is thinking what
if they're gonna find out
is us they have no notion that they
would be on a prank show so i guess
we always keep that in the back of our
minds when we go into it and usually it
runs pretty smooth all right guys i'm
going
in
everybody just calm down well obviously
it reminds me of one of my favorite
prank shows growing up punked
have you ever met ashton actually
kutcher
had nothing to do with frank encounters
and it was for very it was very briefly
was actually at an event a couple of
years ago that was for
i think it must have been after season
two or season three of stranger things
came out
and uh they just happened to be at the
same event and this is before frank
encounters but i got to shake his hand
talk to him for a second i doubt he
remembers but
it was pretty cool and shortly after i
got an offer
to host and executive produce a show
like this and i didn't
turn down that opportunity so that was
pretty cool wait a second
are you serious i'm kind of serious
i've got a pitch for you for season
three what if you guys did
prank encounters celebrity edition were
you just netflix stars
that's funny you say that that's
something that like of course like we
always want to uh
if we're going into more seasons of this
we definitely want to
come up with new ideas that definitely
make it fresh we don't want to just we
don't
don't want it to be too repetitive from
the prior seasons
and in pitch meetings and in discussions
that's been thrown around a couple times
uh
hopefully something can come of it uh
we're not really too
sure though which celebrity or maybe one
of your stranger things coasters are you
most
dying to prank i'm most dying to prank
oh there's some good ones up there i'm
trying to think
when it comes if i was going to prank
anybody on our on stranger things
i'd probably pick noah he's just a riot
man he he knows how to have some fun
and uh i'm just thinking about
what that would what that would entail i
think that'd be fun
that was awesome